foreign
[Music]
hey everybody welcome back to the data
science hangout so nice to see everybody
today
if this is your first time joining us
today I know there was a lot of love for
Matt on LinkedIn so we might have some
people here joining for the very first
time thank you for joining us this is an
open space for the whole data science
Community to connect and chat about data
Science Leadership questions you're
facing and getting to learn about what's
going on in the world of data science
across different Industries and
companies so the sessions are recorded
and they're shared to the posit YouTube
as well as our data science hangout site
so you can always go back and re-watch
or find helpful resources
together at the data science Hangouts
were created we're dedicated to creating
a welcoming environment for everybody so
we love when you all can participate and
we can hear from everyone no matter your
area of work or level of experience too
there's always multiple ways and you can
ask questions and not just ask questions
but also provide your perspective so if
there's something you want to jump in
and weigh in on you can jump in by
raising your hand on Zoom here you could
put questions or comments into the zoom
chat and feel free to put a little star
next to it if you want me to read it too
I see a lot happening in the chat right
now but I could also call on you to
introduce yourselves and add some
context too
we also have a slider link where you can
ask questions anonymously
and our team will put that into the chat
in just a second here
but with all that thanks again for
joining I'm so excited to be joined by
my co-host today Matt dancho founder of
business science and we're just talking
Matt and I spoke at the our studio
conference back in July about the
Hangouts really like let's get something
on the books and here we we finally are
so thanks for joining Matt I'd love to
have you introduce yourself and maybe
share a little bit about
the work you do and yeah yeah well uh
first off Rachel so uh thanks so much
for having me
um you know we were chatting and
we we had talked about doing this back
in July
which was when the our studio conference
was going on and like you said I mean
things have just like flown by and here
we are in November and this is this is
exciting um I'm excited to be here so
thank you so much for having me
um just to introduce myself my name is
Matt if you guys haven't ever met me
before
um you know it's great to meet you
thanks so much for showing up
um you know I don't know
what your background is it sounds like
there might be you know beginners
experts maybe a mix here
um so do me a favor if you're a beginner
can you put like a uh you know just like
a three in the chat just put a put a the
number three so I can get a kind of a
sense of where we're at
all right all right all right okay and
if you're an expert put like a five in
the chat
yeah
all right
cool so we got a good mix of people so
that I like to ask this just so I know
like you know kind of how to
um before I start like diving into like
what I do and everything
um just to kind of get like a general
consensus on you know well we got a
negative five
um you know just just to see where you
guys are at um skill wise and the cool
thing is no matter where you're coming
from you know you're going to learn
stuff we're we're here we're open like
Rachel said we're open
um so feel free to ask questions
um a little bit about myself uh my name
is Matt damcho uh I've been doing R for
about
I want to say like 2013 was like
officially my moment when I like yeah
I'm like I'm going you know full into
this thing uh which back then it was
just kind of like statistics or it
wasn't even I don't think quite called
data science
but um
and you know I've been I've been like I
you know I I don't know if you guys you
guys probably can't identify with this I
got I I got bit by the r bug bad
um like I became obsessed and I just
started like learning as much as I
possibly could and trying to apply it to
my day job at the time which I was
working for a small company
um called Bonnie Forge
and I was just helping them you know
handle their customer data
um work with uh
the manufacturing team I understand like
back then there was a big uh drop in oil
prices and the products that we made
went into oil so I was doing like a lot
of forecasting and things of those
things things of that nature so fast
forward to today
um in 2018 I kind of got into
2017-2018 I got into Consulting kind of
as a side hustle at first and then it
slowly became my full-time job
and then
um in 2018 I pivoted into education
because that's where I really saw a huge
demand for uh you know as I was doing a
lot of these Consulting projects for
companies and like the marketing domain
or Finance domain you know it was it was
clear to me that the problem wasn't that
they needed a consultant they really
needed education and they needed help so
uh in 2018 I founded business science
that's my company
and um since then I've been building a
lot of courses that's what the first
four years were and now uh we're getting
to the point where we're starting to add
additional programs and scale up the
programs too so now we have about uh I
think four four or five thousand
students
and uh you know in 2018 we started with
one so it's been kind of a wild ride are
any of you guys uh students business
science students on the call today uh
you put like a one in the chat
all right sweet sweet so what was really
cool back in art studio conference I got
to meet a ton of my students I met uh I
think over 30 students of mine uh and
it's really cool
um I got pictures with them got to talk
with them got to see them face to face
and I had no clue like I didn't even
think I was gonna run into a single
student and uh it just
um you know it really it's kind of uh
for me it's like a humbling moment
because you know I see like business
Science Education is getting out there
and it's having an impact and you know
those are the the cool things that I
like to see so all right
yeah I probably went a little deeper
than what you may have wanted but uh
sorry we had a little determina asked
that our studio co-host to help with the
mute buttons here let's see
there we go thanks everybody
um I do see some questions already
coming in Matt and this is one that I
actually was really interested to ask
you about as well like your journey
going from your company to starting your
own business and the the question says
Matt I'm really eager could you take us
through your journey to becoming a mini
celeb in the space was it scary to go
off and do your own thing
it was
um so kind of give you so I'll I'll talk
a little bit about you know what was
going on
um so the tough part for me was giving
up a six-figure like a cushy six-figure
job salary uh to do something new and uh
take on a risk and I think as an
entrepreneur
um it's something that I've always
wanted to do but you never really know
kind of when when the timing is right
so
um I had in 2017 I had started
slowly kind of I I made the decision to
like build my first course and I didn't
know like what it was going to do uh I
launched it in 2018 I think it was like
April or May of 2018 and I got like 50
people in it really quick
so that was that to me was like a huge
signal that there was an actual demand
was it enough to offset my salary and
like you know feel like oh yeah I'm
gonna you know do it
no not at all
um so some things happened uh later
throughout that year
um in 20 uh I want to say maybe middle
of 2018 so like August of 2018. I ended
up making the decision to leave my
company
um and again give up that that cushy job
it was a huge risk at that point
um and I remember
uh you know even throughout that year I
remember in this in December of that
year I think I only made like three or
four thousand dollars that that month
and this is coming from somebody who was
making like a lot like probably three or
four times that amount every month
um and you know there was definitely
some question marks like
am I gonna be able to like pull this off
but um you know for me the things that
really help when I decided to actually
like take that step forward
was
um sitting down looking at the numbers
figuring out what people want talking to
customers talking to my students at that
time figuring out what they their needs
were
and then
um really just giving it my all uh I
looked at the numbers and I saw that hey
if we could do you know
this amount each month you know we're
going to be able to be fine we're you
know my wife she was still working full
time at that point
um and
you know it was just like all right
that for me was like okay
January of 2019 I you know I put my head
down and it just started working and
building courses and and uh and after
reviewing the numbers and got the
confidence in myself
to uh to really be able to do it
um and I just I just started doing it
that's great and something that we've
talked about a few times on on past
weeks of the hangout is on building your
personal brand and I think that's
something that you do a really great job
of is I know we originally met on
LinkedIn I think and I was just curious
for for people who are like jumping into
this space too and and looking to build
their their personal brand do you have
any tips for us yeah absolutely
um
so Rachel building your your personal
brand and you and you know this because
you've done a fantastic job as well
especially with being part of our studio
and pause it
um I think you're doing a fantastic job
at this but like everyone can really
benefit from building a personal brand
it doesn't matter if you're you know
trying to get a job
if you're trying to build your own
company if you're you know trying to do
even just you know kind of grow yourself
personally and kind of step out of your
comfort zone I think it's really
important for everyone to build their
own brand uh some tips I can give you
so you're gonna you know don't don't
feel like you need to get it perfect
um
the uh there's a guy that I follow uh on
Twitter his name is uh Justin Welsh and
he does a really good job at like for
people who are trying to like start
their own business
um how to how to uh do your own personal
brand and some of the things like some
of the value that I've gotten from him
uh talking about your journey
like no matter where you are
just you know every day just going on
LinkedIn or maybe every you know make it
make it a point like two three times a
week just put a post out there or
something new that you've learned or
something that you're interested in and
it doesn't have to be like a whole
production because this is the mistake
that I always made was uh I always felt
like my copy has to be like super on
point and it needs to be like something
I've thought about for like days or you
know and all that stuff does work
I think what is more valuable is like
being authentic and just kind of showing
like hey you know I'm not perfect I'm I
learned something I'm excited about it
you know I've learned this new r package
people identify with that and then you
start to grow your followers
um and that can lead to new job
opportunities that can lead to you know
you never know who who that connection
is going to be
and they may be the person that helps
you because we all need help right
um you know no matter
where you are uh you know you're not
going to get you're not going to be you
know you're not going to be the best
version of yourself without getting a
little bit of help along the way and um
and I think using LinkedIn and using
Twitter to that and just posting a
little bit about your journey every you
know doesn't have to be every day
every couple times each week really
that'll make a huge difference
thank you that's really helpful
and uh I'm starting to see some
questions coming into through the chat
too so Jeremy I see you just asked a
question do you want to jump in live and
ask it
foreign
I see you unmuted but I'm not sure yet
oh there you are hey I'm just interested
uh I do some online teaching and I do a
lot of meetings online I'm still working
from home so I'm just interested in like
how you what technology you use to get
the best experience uh when you're
connecting with people remotely hardware
and software and how do you integrate R
into these uh Technologies
okay okay so
um so good great question Jeremy uh
the the main types of softwares that I
use I mean Zoom I do I do a webinar uh
once every
um I'm actually doing I was doing it
every two weeks now I'm gonna do it
every week uh but I usually try to do
like a webinar and I try to teach a
little bit about our
um and certain you know topics uh one
that's one that I'm actually getting
ready to teach is time series I'm going
to be doing that next week but every
every week or every couple of weeks I
try to get you know on a zoom webinar uh
with
I just open it up to everybody because
you know it's kind of a way to give back
um it's it's something that I'm very uh
interested in helping people uh grow
there are experience because I think I
think too like oftentimes you see people
out there and they just don't know about
r or they may be on like the edge of
like should I should I do data science
could I do data science you know I'm
working in Excel right now I'm doing
power bi uh but like what else can I do
be doing to grow my career so
doing a webinar so Zoom for webinars is
fantastic
um trying to think what else obviously I
use the rstudio product line
um and or the posit product line but our
studio the IDE is fantastic
uh shiny I think that is such like a
misunderstood technology out there that
like people
kind of often Overlook so I love
showcasing shiny as a as a way to like
really take R into production because
everyone always talks about like you
know ml Ops and and you know putting
things into production how do you do
that with r
guys it's right there it's shiny
um it's fantastic and um let's see what
else what else what other Technologies
do I use
I mean through my business I I probably
touch 30 or 40 different Technologies
um and we could probably talk all day
about those but do you have anything
specific Jeremy that you're interested
in
no I'm just interested in kind of you
know hearing about how you keep people
engaged who've been in meetings all day
and then you know tune in to a another
Zoom meet up so so yeah so okay this is
this is good because
um something I started working with is
actually a coach and a um uh and a
marketing guy as well
and that's really helped me in my
presentation skills because in the on
the online age it's really tough to
capture people's engagement
so
um I don't know how deep Rachel you want
to go into the art of uh of kind of
presentations let's dive in whatever
everybody wants yeah all right if you
guys want to go I'll go I mean so
all right there's
when you do a presentation
um you know people are on Zoom calls all
day you know with covet and everything
the last thing you want to do is you
want to you want to just kind of like
get on to a zoom call and just talk at
people for 60 minutes and that's the
last thing that they want to do too
because you know they're going to be
you know after the first three minutes
they're gonna tune you out right so what
we started doing on our marketing
webinars and on our technical webinars
is really just trying to keep the
engagement up so like like what I did
here with like the threes and the fives
that's a that's a way to engage um so
you just ask a question to the audience
and oftentimes you know that that keeps
them kind of in there that much longer
um
questions talking so the way I used to
uh I have a note on my um on my keyboard
don't be boring
and so I will do like weird stuff like
um I'll kind of I've started to like
um play around with the way that I talk
so I used to kind of like talk just like
like I would conversationally but in a
in a webinar like you want to talk a
little bit differently you want to
actually accentuate
you know your speech patterns So like
um if you have kind of a long sentence
you know I'm talking about our studio
how great it is and I want to make sure
that you get the most important
information today that you know and this
these are the three things I want you to
walk away with so I'll like
I play around with my speech a little
bit that that those inflection points
will keep people interested and
um and also uh starting everything with
a big promise like you know hey what why
are you here today like what are you
gonna get out of it so I started doing
like this big promise at the beginning
of my of my webinars and I just started
saying you know hey I'm gonna teach you
like one thing today if you don't walk
away from this presentation with
anything else this is what you're gonna
do today and you know like for my time
series presentation or for like I just
did a one-on text analysis
um you know it was one skill that
they're gonna learn that is really gonna
like
allow them to improve their model
performance and potentially save their
company up to a million dollars so
something big that they're going to walk
away and they're going to they're going
to see at the end
um how how we accomplish that I think I
think you do a couple of those things
and you're going to see that you're you
know your Zoom calls your webinars that
you're on especially if you're training
data scientists like some of that stuff
can get dull pretty quickly
and I often talk I I often think that
the more that they can identify you with
you as the person
um so I saw I'll mix in a little bit of
my story usually in the beginning of my
talks and I feel like that especially
for new people that aren't you know
accustomed to you yet I think that that
makes a big difference
so that was a good question yeah great
thank you
that's really helpful Matt too I've been
thinking a lot about a lot of the
communities that people build within
their own companies too and getting
people engaged and interested in those
that's really helpful snippet for us
yeah and I think case studies too like
like people often in companies like what
I saw is even though you're on the same
team A lot of times you don't uh you
don't see what they're doing so sharing
just a case study or an example of how
you're using R in that company can
oftentimes help grow R within what you
know inside the walls because you know
you might be in the Marketing Group but
the manufacturing group may have a
similar situation that you know they
don't even know that it can help them so
yeah
absolutely share share tell stories talk
about your case studies all that's
really good stuff
Marley and I I see you asked a question
in the chat do you want to jump in
door hey Matt
um good morning or afternoon
I'm in Key West right now so yeah I'm uh
East Coast time zone it is uh just noon
just hit noon so
nice to see you mark Marlene
we just had the time shift so I'm super
discombobulated people
um my question was around
um
it's starting to kind of socialize data
sharing
um and it it's a struggle for certain
organizations right and I'm just
wondering if you handled that a bit as a
consultant like I mean obviously you
deal a lot with the the real Hands-On
date of work but how do you start to
address or or like I said socialize the
concept of breaking down some silos and
and barriers to data sharing I don't
know if you can just say it's as easy as
our studio connect or whatever you
recommend or I don't know how do you
kind of start having that conversation
so so I'm a big fan of including as many
stakeholders throughout the project as
possible so a typical example might be
like if I was doing a Consulting project
with
um like one of the companies I've worked
with back in the day like s p Global
um mrm McCann they're a big marketing
firm s p Global they're on they're in
the finance
so what I'll do like I normally have a
point of contact there that I'm working
with but what I'll try and do is as we
come up with the project
um you know Discovery phase I'll ask a
lot of questions like what are your pain
points where which you know how does
this affect your organization like
really try to like go a couple layers
deep with them
and what ends up happening is they'll be
like oh yeah well this you know this
affects this part of the company I was
like well you know should we involve
them in the conversation
and they're like yeah it's probably not
a bad idea so you start like kind of
building a a group of people and then
once you get them all kind of you know
filled in on on what you guys are trying
to do
that often um just helps break down the
silos and they can kind of understand
and talk in an open you know Forum where
everyone's equal and uh and just really
try to like understand this you know
whatever that problem is because most of
the time the you know the data science
team
you're kind of acting like a consultant
a lot of times you know my impression of
is is they're almost doing like a
Consulting capacity inside of an
organization so the toughest part is to
like be able to get everyone comfortable
so that number one they give you access
to data
but number two get you know just get
them talking and communicating so that
way you really can
you know break down those like
I don't know I don't know if they're
like
kind of like silos or barriers whatever
whatever you want to call it but you got
to break those down so everyone's um
talking and then that that's going to
make them more comfortable for sure
got it yeah I appreciate that it's um
it's a struggle and you you hit the nail
right on the head and operating on a
kind of like a consultancy that's what I
feel like I am running around to about
we have or a family of companies six
companies so each of the companies
saying what what's the what's top of the
priority list what are you trying to
automate and or sure I'm on a five or
six year plan to get us into machine
learning so it's it's gonna be a long
long bill but what company do you work
with if you don't mind me asking
sure I work for Western Growers we're on
a trade Association for
um specialty crops Growers so not corn
not many of those
um so basically if you enjoy leafy
greens anybody on the call um we take
care of the Growers all over the country
90. California yeah thank you okay
yeah
I mean it's you know
it's not going to happen overnight so
I'm glad you guys have like a actual
plan that you guys are working to
although you might be surprised you can
get it done probably faster than five
years you know depending on how large
your organization is and how much of
that uh what do they call it um
corporate inertia uh so to speak but um
yeah in the technology will play a big
role too so you mentioned our studio
connect I think that's a fantastic
product I think
um
you know just getting quick wins like
anything anytime you can get like
something simple quick out there
that is going to be that's gonna gain
their confidence in you and and your
ability to manage that project
and I think that that's going to help
you grow
um your your uh your your net the net
that you're trying to cast
so that that's what I recommend yeah go
for go for quick wins
um get them all in meetings you know
communicate make sure you go a couple
levels deep with them
thank you so much yeah I mean I don't
want to dominate the call because there
are a lot of other questions but there's
a lot going on here that I'm just
throwing tons of irons in the fire and
trying to build some traction here and
definitely going for easy times so
thanks so much Matt I appreciate it yep
you got it you got it no problem I'm
seeing lots of love for both shiny and
leafy greens in the chat right now
um Alan I see you asked a question you
want to jump in
sure yeah hi Matt
um I'm really really curious about the
sort of identity of the company as you
call it business science and wanted to
get you to maybe speak to that a little
bit more I read it as being
intentionally specific about the
embeddedness of data work in
organizations and towards Focus business
problem solving and a little bit
different from a lot of the positioning
of data science learning as like you
know hardcore data science
um and I wonder if that if that's true
and if so how do you kind of like what
does that mean for the way you design
your courses for the way you sort of you
know pitch what the what the company
does for people
um and and that sort of thing like how
is that a kind of day-to-day part of the
identity of the company
right oh that's a good question Alan and
I'm really glad you brought that up so
um the identity of my company business
science has actually evolved over time
um initially you know I was just trying
to combine business and data science in
in a way and I'm a very kind of like I
want to be it to be obvious you know
what the what the naming of the company
I'm not like a company like apple where
I'm gonna like you know call myself
apple and then it's going to be a you
know technology company that builds you
know phones and and computers and those
sorts of things and all the other stuff
that they do now so
I wanted to like that's their uh
originally why I called it business
science and again my roots were in
Consulting so I was actually applying
data science to business and that's
really was the Crux of what I was trying
to go after and when I was coming up
with the training initially that's
really what I wanted to
um you know emphasize is like a business
forward or a business first type of way
of learning data science now with that
said things things have changed a lot in
the past four years or five years that
I've been running this thing and I will
say this like
seriously
I I actually view
um and we can get like at a at a like a
really deep level of conversation on
this but
um I I really view that data scientists
and like data analysts um I think that
there's going to be a new role here in
the next couple of years that companies
are going to start adopting the role of
the business scientists because you
already have a business analyst and I
haven't really talked a whole lot about
this yet but like the more I think about
it
uh the problem the problem and the
challenge with data science and why
companies often like fail with data
science it's not because they they have
they don't have good people or they
don't have you know problem solvers or
this or that
but they lose sight of the business
first mentality where you need to be
able to start with a problem in an
organization be able to work with many
different levels of the organization
from Executives to line managers to
people who are doing the work and you
have to work cross-functionally and
cross-sectionally throughout the the
um the company
and that to me requires like a heavy
business Acumen like not just a like hey
I know data and I know a few algorithms
that I can throw at the data like no
that's that's not how it goes like the
most successful people that I've seen
are the ones that are able to
communicate effectively that know what
the target is of the organization the
objectives uh and they can translate
that into like all the different you
know they can kind of take that down and
and and translate it across the the
organization
so I view the more and more that I think
about this I really view that there's
probably in the next you know couple of
years you're going to start seeing like
actual roles on like
um you know within companies like on
indeed for the business scientists and
I'm going to start promoting that here
actually
um you know start probably uh in the in
2023 you'll see more
um of me talking about that so good good
question that's great thanks I I love
hearing that Evolution and your your the
way that what you're seeing in the
industry and in companies is informing
how how you're you're thinking moves and
really really resonates everything
you're saying about
um uh being tightly connected about the
work matters because it's solving
problems that people need us to solve
um yeah really really cool thanks
awesome well thanks a lot for that
question Alan
yeah thank you
that was my that was my daughter Shea
she's uh
this this came in to say hi here I'm
gonna shut the door real quick no
worries
hey Rachel hey yes I was gonna say jump
in there and actual site I see your
Andres yeah so it's funny Eugene just
made a comment on this along the same
lines of where I'm thinking so
um my team at Peloton just got a new VP
um and one of the very first things that
he began talking about is product
management within our team which is kind
of Shifting us away from this project
management based style of intake and
like prioritization to strictly like
aligning ourselves with stakeholders so
I wanted to ask you Matt how that's
played out in your organization how do
you prioritize how do you like
share responsibilities across your team
like what's your org chart do you have
product managers how do they interact
with your developers like just trying to
get a sense of how it works
how do you run yourself basically yeah
yeah so so business science is a small
company
um we are up to seven or eight now
um but mainly uh you know
compared to probably Peloton which has a
lot more than eight people
um so we so in my shop you know I wear a
lot of hats uh my wife she's you know
she's working uh doing you know working
with like businesses actual companies
also working like with customer service
and finance
um so we have like everyone you know at
business science we all wear a lot of
different hats we do have some role
players we've got people that are
marketing I've uh Consultants that I've
actually hired out to that are
um you know helping me with different
products that were getting ready to
launch or have launched already
um we now have a sales team but that's
kind of like the extent of it
um as I'm growing in this capacity and
this is really new to me
um because a year ago we were three
people at this time
um it was me my wife and then I just had
hired my first Like official marketing
guy named his name's Mike
um so so Mike joined the team and then
fast forward uh a year later and now
we're at seven so we're starting to grow
a little bit faster now
um but what I've seen is for me
personally uh the challenges are way
different because being a course creator
you know it's more technical in nature
I'm thinking about like what does the
student need to learn how do I package
this into a product that's gonna you
know effectively walk them through all
the major things uh but still be like
business forward and and uh and you know
get them at the early win
um and and take them through a whole
business project but now
while I'm still creating courses
actually some of that has slowed down
and now what I'm emphasizing more in my
role is leadership so leadership is uh
something that anybody can learn
uh it's
um you know definitely a learnable skill
and it starts with caring so that's this
is the funny thing
um I've started to like actually like
call people up and just like you know
let them know that I care about them and
talk with them you know on a personal
level like hey where are you trying to
go in your life what are you trying to
do and how can business science best
help you get there and I think that's
something that's like
maybe a little weird it could be a
little weird at first but like it's it's
something unique that I do that that has
really helped me like kind of identify
with people and really get to understand
them more and when when I show them like
okay this is how business science can
help you grow if you're trying to become
a better data scientist and also you
know working for my company
um
you know how does that relate to what
you're doing at Peloton
um
you know there's definitely we can all
get better at leadership and I think
that that's really when you when you're
working at even if you're as a project
manager where you aren't necessarily
like overseeing people but you but you
do effectively have to get them to do
things in order to help you do the
project right
so you know just having that level of
kind of a you know leading by example
um and
you know getting to know the person
uh showing them how your project is
going to help them do better with
whatever their goals are are
um and how it's going to help them make
things easier make it make it easier for
them or or increase their status in the
company like like simple things like and
it doesn't have to be
um
like like people think like people are
motivated by money all the time that's
that's a load of bull uh what people are
really motivated by honestly is
things like simple things like
recognition
um you know if they're going to be part
of the team and this thing's a success
you know I'm gonna recognize you and I
want you to know that going into this
like you're going to be up there with
the whole team uh and we're gonna we're
gonna you know showcase you know
everything that that uh went into this
project
and um yeah simple things like that that
can actually like especially if you're a
project manager can really help so I
don't know if that makes sense I don't
know if that's helpful or not but that's
my two cents at least
yeah definitely all those things are in
true and
um relevant to my situation here so
thank you so much you got it
thank you Matt one I see you asked a
great question in the chat a bit earlier
um if you're still on which you want to
jump in and ask that
uh now I I was wondering how do you get
over the Imposter syndrome
I've been working with data since
sociologists 20 years ago but with our
full-time signs
2015-16 but I don't consider myself a
data scientist or a data analyst even
though I'm not sociologist with
political science I I work with
electoral data a polio competing data
Twitter data but I I don't know how to
get that step to consider myself a data
scientist thank you so yeah so one this
is a great one so I would venture to say
you're not alone uh just a show of hands
anybody else experience imposter
syndrome at any point in your career
just uh put a put a put a six in the
chat put a six we'll do a six
all right all right so so one you're
seeing the chat right
yes lots of people are having imposter
syndrome too so that's the first thing
I would say probably 90 of data
scientists experience some level of
imposter syndrome uh it's very common I
experienced it I'll get I'll share you
my I'll share with you my story and kind
of some of the things that I did to get
get over it
but um
my problem was uh so I I'm a data
scientist like self-trained I never went
to school for data science
um I was a mechanical engineer I've
worked in the valve industry uh mainly
doing like actually design work and and
uh and maintenance uh efforts and then
kind of managing a like actual team of
uh Engineers that that did uh that build
valves basically
um
I eventually got into the sales group
because they liked what I what I was
doing uh managerially with with that
Engineering Group so I got some some
additional responsibility and I started
to you know kind of work my way up in
the organization but uh I started
learning data science
and uh
it wasn't easy like it was it was far
from it
um honestly
it took me probably three at least four
or five years to think of myself as an
actual data scientist and there were
some days when I was going through it I
remember like trying to make reports and
just like nothing's coming together I'm
drawing blanks I'm just staring at the
screen like the cursor's blinking at me
and I'm just like
map pull it together like
you know what what the heck's wrong but
um so like people go through that and I
venture to say like at least
you know 9 out of 10 data scientists
right I mean it's it's pretty common
so uh things things that can help things
that help me
don't give up like every day is a new
day so try and write at least one line
of code a day that was something that I
implemented in my own personal journey
and I did that for like
I don't know seven or eight years
straight and that single activity of
like saying like hey I gotta pull up our
studio I gotta start you know I just got
to put one line of code in there and you
know what's gonna happen it's a mental
thing because you're going to write more
than one line of code like who's gonna
stop at one line of code right I mean it
takes you you know
um so so anyways I started doing that I
started being consistent with my habits
um I started really like doubling down
on some of the things that I was
learning like ggplot just getting
visualizations those are quick wins once
I learned ggplot I could then start
telling stories to my management team
and that was you know something that
like
nobody else in my company was doing so I
started focusing on things like that
that weren't like necessarily overly
complex like machine learning or
anything like that I kind of set some of
that stuff aside and really focused on
the foundational things I got really
good with data wrangling that was
another area where
like people in my company had tough
times when there was you know especially
in a SQL database where you've got like
you know a jillion tables which ones do
you pull in so I learned like one table
like the customer table I learned at the
transactions table
um I learned uh how to connect the two
and start to blend the data and this is
stuff that like people had a really
tough time with in my company and and it
was something that differentiated me and
again just a quick win you start to
learn you know handful deep plier
functions like group by and summarize I
mean how how often is that like exactly
the one-two punch that your boss needs
in order to be able to to gain insights
so
um you know I really focused on some of
those
the problem one of my biggest mistakes
is I would get on LinkedIn
and honestly I would see everyone
talking about deep learning this was
back
2016 you know they would be talking
about tensorflow Keras
that for me was a huge black hole I got
no I got very limited value out of that
stuff I actually true story I built a a
regression model for my company
that ended up like honestly no joke
helping me take the the part of the
company that I was overseeing from about
three million to 15 million uh in
revenue and it was a small part of the
company because the company made about
like 500 million a year in Revenue so
this is like a kind of a drop in the
bucket but like
that you know my boss saw that and my
boss's boss saw that and they're like oh
wow this is this is really you know in
pretty impressive what you're doing it
was it was a i implemented a lead
scoring algorithm that um
uh literally was just a logistic
regression
now true story I then I was getting good
results with that so I was like oh this
deep learning stuff this is pretty cool
right you know I was thinking to myself
I was seeing like what people were doing
online with it and they're like oh my
gosh I can do image classification I can
do this and that
so I I hauled off and I was like all
right I'm Gonna Learn deep learning at
least the basics and I'm gonna like try
to apply it to this uh
lead scoring problem
and I spent probably six months on that
and I got nothing out of it uh my
logistic regression model was better
um just trying to like understand
tensorflow and then realizing tensorflow
is too complicated so then I'm going to
switch to Keras and then oh somebody's
talking about Pi torch I can't actually
I can't even remember Pi torch was out
back then but you know it's just the
process of like seeing all these like
I call them red herrings like they're uh
you know these shiny objects out there
that are trying to like steal your
attention and it's taking you away from
like the thing that you're um that's
actually getting you the value
so data wrangling ggplot you know work
on those get the get the foundations get
the basics done
um and get the quick wins and then kind
of work your way up as you go
um then machine learning ended up being
really powerful for me and some other
stuff
so I hope that helps
thank you Matt for doing the numbers
thing too because I think it's like it's
always helpful to just see how many
other people are feeling that as well
yep yep no it's imposter syndrome is a
big one even my students a lot of them
that's that's sometimes the reason that
they're that can be like honestly the
sole reason that they take that they
jump into my program is because you know
whatever they're taking they uh
you know it's just
not getting them through they always
feel like every for two steps forward
they're taking one step backwards so you
know you hate to see that and that's you
know that's something I'm I'm on a
mission to help my my students at least
get through that
definitely
um I I see you had your hand raised too
I know sea of Ash how's it going man hi
Matt I'm a student and proudest student
I'm really enjoying the time series
course
um I already thought that it was like a
I'm a I'm already doing a lot of Time
series so it's gonna be a quick course
but it's like
a lot of functions that I struggled and
I spent a lot of time to just write them
it's like some of these helper functions
make my life much easier and I'm still
not throughout the course so I
appreciate that
um my question is what is the next big
thing on in business science I'm very
looking forward what you're working on
and when it will be coming so so I'm
working on two big things right now
um the first one is actually
um
a a a program that combines so
uh for those of you who don't know how
business science is structured I have a
core product which is called the five
course R track the time series course
that CMOS is taking is the third course
in that system and it's basically
designed to kind of take you from
wherever you are now to you know being
super productive being able to
out-compete all of your competition if
you're trying to get a job or if you're
already have a job and you're trying to
apply data science give you all the
skills necessary you know things like
shiny
um things like the data wrangling the
visualization time series which was a
huge win for me when I was working
um back in the day for Bonnie Forge but
the um the next big thing is to kind of
take that system and add on an
additional course to it but also
um so the course the the additional
course is uh to help get you a data
science job in 30 days and then the
whole package is designed to also add in
a coach a personalized coach that takes
you through the entire program in under
180 days along with a whole group that
goes through the process with you so one
of the big hurdles that I was Finding is
that you know some some people like cvos
like you you know you're you're highly
self-motivated and you're crushing the
courses
but these courses I mean they're pretty
dense because they go deep into like how
to solve the business problems and and
get you and that's where you get the
value out of it but it's very easy for
life to or like you know a curveball to
come and to get sidetracked and then you
know staying motivated so we want to
have a coach that helps take you through
that whole process
um somebody who's and it's designed for
people who want to get data science
positions
so that way
um whether they want to get a senior
data science position you know through
the beta program
I've already had
one student get the get a job at Air
Canada uh she got it in four months
using this program
um another student uh she's a she's 22
years old her name's hobby I actually
hired her on as my next coach because
she is so fantastically good at getting
a data science interview it's
disgustingly scary
but uh she has like all the tricks in
the book and she knows how to take that
the the curriculum she like you guys
have to have to hear this she had no
prior data science experience like
working as a data science data scientist
she had no prior working experience
other than
um she used to sell wine through for her
dad's business uh she um her dad owned a
a company that distributed wine so
she was able to uh in seven months with
this program be able to get her first
data science job she just landed
um landed at here about two weeks ago
uh at the Federal Reserve in many in
Minnesota so Minneapolis Minnesota so
she crushed it and I had to hire her on
because she had everything stacked
against her uh no working experience
prior to that
so that's that's the first thing that
I'm working on uh we're getting ready to
productionalize that because I have to
have a sales team to help
um sell that it's a look it's a it's a
higher ticket product because of the
coaching aspect but the results that it
gets are are amazing
um so at the productionize that just
takes a little bit more work so we're
probably going to be launching that here
in January and then
um the other thing that I have in beta
right now is uh I'm leveraging I I kind
of I always seek my past for guidance
and
um one of the things I'm doing right now
is with Consulting I'm teaching people
who have uh who are dangerous with R to
to learn how to turn that into a
business whether it's a side hustle or
actually
um creating a scalable business model
that
um you know I'm teaching them how to do
things like find their Niche
how to develop an offer that there's
Market demand for already out there
how to create a business
and how to basically do everything from
take the to generate leads to building
out a sales presentation and selling
clients and the goal is is to land uh 25
000 Plus data science projects and then
to be able to
scale that so that way what they do
their first client their first client
pays them to build it and then their
next client they shrink the time because
they've got already got most of the code
written already and they can reproduce
it and it becomes a scalable business
model so that's the uh that's that's the
next project I'm working on right now um
I have nine students in that beta
program and uh we're just through the
first week of it right now but it's
going really well so far so cross my
fingers I'm hoping to launch that
probably mid mid next year
awesome thank you very much
Matt I know you have a hard stop at the
top of the hour with kids running in on
vacation too so I want to make sure to
get to a few a few other questions that
I know Frank you asked one in the chat a
bit earlier I was trying to scroll up
and find it if you want to ask live here
and go quick uh so Matt thinking about
your classes putting right like
remembering back to when I was taking
him and then you were talking about the
webinars and some of the techniques that
you learned and you used to keep people
on the call through the whole webinar
um it made me wonder about some of the
analytics behind people taking the
courses and if there's anything that you
learn there about how data people either
like to learn or how they learn and how
you like use that to change how you
create courses one of the things that
comes to mind is
um what is the data science topic that
like we 2x playback speed through the
most frequently
anything like that so so I find I find
Learners are either 2x Learners 1.5 x
Learners or 1X Learners so no matter
what they once they get the hang of how
to do 2x it's like you never gonna go
back right
I do too I do like at least one and a
half X on all my YouTube videos that's
how I crush your a lot of content a lot
of times
um and and I find that a lot of uh
Learners when it comes to like analyzing
like how they how they learn
um
so one of the biggest metrics that I
started out with was uh understanding
um
if my courses were better than the the
rest in the market
so I pride myself on as just like as a
kind of an online format it is insanely
tough to even get people to take your
course right
so
a couple of things we do differently
um that I think the slack Channel with
the support getting the support as soon
as they have a problem they can hop in
there uh get in you know ask any
question no questions off the table
um and really get feedback at the speed
of learning I think that's incredibly
important when I implemented that that
really helped kind of take my um uh uh
completion rates up now the other thing
so having a community like that really
helped uh
keeping videos small I think that's
super critical so there's this there's
this thing um I can't remember the name
of the curve but people people learn
kind of in a it's like a U-shaped curve
so if you do like an hour webinar
uh people only remember the first part
of it and and the end of it like in the
middle they're only gonna their chances
of memorized or remembering that it's
like three to five percent but at the
beginning and end so if you can shrink
that time down and one of the things I
did was I tried to keep no video uh
longer than five minutes so you're gonna
at least remember the beginning and end
of each of those videos and then it's
also going to be like Eminem they're
just going to pop one after the other
right rather than happen to you know eat
a whole big like pile at once right so
those are some of the things that I
started implementing that really um I
saw move the needle for my program
um a lot of other stuff that we do
differently uh starting off with a
business problem first I think that's
super critical
um getting them a quick win showing them
like a jump start like not a full
analysis but a bite size analysis so
they can begin with the end in mind they
can kind of see and visualize how this
course is going to play out and how that
value is going to stack and then by the
end of it they're like you know uh
Beyond thrilled because uh they they saw
just at the beginning you know what
they're going to accomplish
um that's funny about the jumpstarter
because I felt yeah I feel like I had
learned the whole class after the jump
start I got my value and then it's just
and then it's just fitting in the pieces
and going just a little bit deeper with
some of the concepts yeah so once you
get through the jump start like you you
already you know where you're going it's
just how do I get there and then get the
a lot of its muscle memory like
repetition with some of those functions
um and just you know really kind of like
you know
um understanding how people learn
uh in terms of data science I don't do a
whole lot of data science on analytics
on like actually the The Learning
Journey
um I do more analytics now one of the
big things that really helped me was
understanding uh as my email list has
grown uh that everybody is not
necessarily like you know one size fits
all hit them with the r track uh you
know they're you know a portion of them
are going to buy and yes certainly that
that certain you know that's that's true
but we're starting now to get segments
that like are very new and maybe they
just need like a beginner you know or
maybe they want a book at first to like
kind of warm them up to me
um rather than you know and certainly
some people are ready to jump into like
the the r track uh and that's what I
that's what I normally sell especially
if they are on a webinar
um I'm going to you know present that
offer to them because normally if
they're investing like an hour plus time
you know they're pretty committed at
that point but but some people you know
especially if they're just like
teetering on like the edge of like what
is data science
is it right for me you know that's
that's a different product that's like a
book so we gotta like start to
understand our customers where they're
at in their own Learning Journey and
present the right offer at the right
time in order to be able to help them
through that process
that was awesome thank you
thank you so much Matt for joining us
today I know we're getting right to the
top of the hour and you have to run but
there's a few questions that went
unanswered is it okay if I send those
over to you maybe on LinkedIn and yeah
yeah so so so full disclosure guys I'm
down here with my family uh in Key West
Florida uh we're we're trying to uh
enjoy we got a flight at five o'clock so
I'm trying to uh enjoy the last little
bit of pool time I'm gonna have with my
kids
um but um yeah definitely Rachel send me
those questions over we'll get them
answered I'll uh I'll do that promptly
hopefully by tomorrow or the weekend
I'll get them back to you and uh wait
till wait till next week you go go run
to the pool time right now don't worry
about it all right another question
thank you so much Matt for joining us
yeah it was so great being on here guys
honestly Rachel it's an honor for you to
invite me on here and whatever you guys
are doing you know just just know that
you're on the right path here with r
with data science it's really going to
help you it helped my career I know it's
going to help you guys too